English language teaching has the same challenges the world over.
This series focuses on teaching speaking.
We've come to Thailand to see how teachers here monitor their students' speaking activities.
And we'll have expert tips from teacher trainer John Kay.
One of the fears of a teacher is that if you're not involved, you're not doing your job properly.
But sometimes doing your job properly means taking a backseat.
Monitoring. Watch what your students are doing. Don't interfere with what your students are doing.
Monitoring requires strategies. Your students are on task, so now what?
First of all, you have to check that the instructions have been understood and the students are working.
If your activity requires your students to work in pairs and you have one person who's leftover,...
...put that person into a group of three...
...so that this frees you to monitor what's happening with all the other pairs.
If your students are holding back, think about why this could be.
Is it because they're fearful of making mistakes? Or is it because they don't feel confident enough?
Or is it perhaps because you're monitoring them too closely?
Stand back, take a backseat, leave them, lose the eye contact...
...so that they don't know that you're there.
Sometimes it's a good idea to actually tell the students what you're monitoring for.
Maybe you're monitoring for pronunciation or accuracy to see how they're actually using the language...
... that they practiced beforehand. Rather than helping them just with the target language,...
... are they using the useful language in their group activity?
If not, maybe you could prompt them in this direction.
But don't stop them from being experimental and using English. Encourage that.
So what do you do if the students just haven't got it? Well go in, help them with it.
But don't interfere too early. Give them a chance to sort it themselves, peer correction.
Are they doing it successfully? If they don't need any help, then stay out of the way. Listen.
If you need to approach a group, OK, go in there, give them a prompt.
But once you've helped out, don't become part of the proceedings. Move on.
If there's one person in the group who is obviously struggling, give them a monitoring task.
They're listening for pronunciation or maybe they're listening for structure or maybe they're listening for use of useful language.
That's their responsibility. They are part of the group and so it's not teacher - dominated.
For correction purposes, make a note...
...and then you can refer to it later. You can also refer to this for future lessons...
If you hear something while you're monitoring that is particularly good,...
...why not tell them, you know, go in there and let them know that it was good.
If you've moved the students around and they've exhausted everything they want to talk about,...
...don't let the task drag on. Leave them on a high. Finish while they're still busy.
Time is up. I'm happy that you like it, but let's wrap up the lesson.
What do we learn today?